petit coup de gueule
j'ai vu un truc là c'est pas du tout
prévu au conducteur on va en parler de
dans un instant que dirait réellement la
plainte de la femme d'Adrien catenas
Myriam
instant alors et on a le gars qu'il
fallait aujourd'hui il paraît qu'il est
chaud comme de l'eau c'est Laurent Méric
porte-parole de enedis enedis c'est
voilà c'est Lolo tout ça j'en ai marre
de ça là je veux qu'il nous donne les
vérités parce que moi j'ai plein de
trucs dessus je vous le dis je sais la
vérité et je vais voir s'il m'a confirme
ce que je vous dis vous avez pas pouvoir
prendre de douche vous avez pas pouvoir
allumer la lumière le seul qui va être
content bah c'est Benjamin parce que ça
soit par là
je vous le dis voilà je vous le dis bon
sinon j'ai vu que la Hidalgo n'allez pas
mettre des grands géants pour voir les
matchs
quelle hypocrisie mais sans déconner
mais quelle hypocrisie mais elle veut
pas fermer sa gueule non mais sans
rigoler elle va pas mettre des grands
géants pour voir les matchs mais qui
elle va pénaliser les Français on va
pénaliser les gens qui ont envie de voir
des matchs elle va pénaliser les joueurs
si ils avaient des excusez moi ils
auraient empêché ils auraient dit on
fait pas la Coupe du monde mais c'est
pas la peine de se réveiller là ça fait
des années qu'on sait qu'elle va se
passer
c'est maintenant qu'il se réveille et
tous les maires du Louvre pas vu
décrochions mais fermez vos gueules
j'espère que non mais sans déconner
quelle bande d'abri dans le salon
vous croyez les vous croyez que Vous
sanctionnez qui sans déconner vous
croyez que Vous sanctionnez qui manque
d'abruti vous êtes non mais votre en
fonctionner qui jeune ils vont
sanctionner français c'est tout bon pas
sanctionner les les gars qui organisé la
Coupe du monde
va chercher les rats la nuit au lieu de
dire des conneries
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas possible stopper là bordel de
merde c'est ta copine toi ta copine toi
je la connais bien je la mets
je suis énervé je vais défoncer tout le
monde
mais bien sûr exactement
dégueulasse c'est une tartufferie par
exemple
[Rires]
commencer déconner au bout de 5 ouais
c'est pardonner déjà
toi tu vas être d'accord avec elle toi
pas du tout ah bah vas-y alors je peux
parler par contre ça y est il y a eu des
morts chez toi
le gars ça y est croque-mort maintenant
non mais sans déconner ça y est quoi
c'est officiel quoi le gars il arrive
qu'est-ce qui se passe tu es encore
billard de monter carrément
l'hypocrisie totale c'est quand vous
prenez Paris ou les entreprises du CAC
40 le Qatar il a implanté partout à
Paris bien sûr sur les Champs-Élysées
moi la personne qui s'occupe des
interdits en France il m'avait emmené
sur les Champs-Élysées il m'avait dit la
moitié des champs bien sûr au kata tous
les hôtels les restaurants et elle et
elle elle est le maire de la mère de la
camionnette
avec elle qui rénove les fontaines
s'imaginez même Laurent Fontaine elle a
été rénovée par des Catalans
qui va nous envoyer quelqu'un demain
qu'on lui parle ça m'étonnerait
[Applaudissements]
de toute façon à faire des travaux
sans déconner entre les travaux les rats
et les couloirs de bus sans déconner
non mais même en vélo maintenant tu peux
plus circuler j'ai comme un Hidalgo à la
fin alors je sais pas si vous connaissez
sa mère de Paris elle a fait la journée
sans voiture sauf que la journée sans
voiture est encore plus dangereuse que
la journée avec voiture parce qu'en fait
tu te retrouves avec les enfants en vélo
et il y a toujours des voitures qui ont
droit de passer donc en fait tu as
quelques voitures plus vite que personne
donc mais c'est pas possible et tu veux
pas t'arrêter le périple boucher mais
sans déconner arrête-toi
mais en fait tu fais que des conneries
en fait non mais sans déconner moi
j'aurais rien à [ __ ] je peux pas
parisien non mais mais les écrans géants
mais elle était ce sera la première à
regarder les matchs en plus chez elle
avec des petits fours et Bernard Montiel
[Applaudissements]